margot margot attend j'ai besoin que tu
meures est ta voiture tu dis quoi ta
voiture mais j'ai pas de voiture celle
de ta mère c'est pareil en outre il faut
que tu la conduisent parce que j'ai une
liste de neuf chose à faire ce soir
et plus de la moitié nécessite la
complicité d'un chauffeur pourquoi tu tu
vas pas commettre un délit rappelle moi
la violation de domicile c'est un délit
bah oui quoi alors il va falloir que je
me sauve alors tiré mais dit oui tu peux
pas aller demander un thé subalternes
jays et si oui car ils font partie du
problème justement que le comblement y
en a neuf des problèmes dont ton petit
copain ex petit copain